the body of australian abu again just
arrived
in the old city for the church service
to mark her death it was being held at a
hospital
in east jerusalem in sheikh jarrah
and we had seen scenes there of violence
from
the israeli police who were objecting to
uh attempts to try and bring her body by
foot uh rather than on a vehicle the
agreement was that she would arrive here
on a vehicle uh but there was an attempt
to bring on foot and the israeli police
were using stun grenades and tear gas
to try and disperse the crowd at the
hospital uh her body is now here uh in
the old city and and the old city in
jerusalem along with a crowd of
thousands and it is still uh very tense
here uh israeli police are out in force
uh and there's been moments when they
have gone into the crowd uh to and it's
unclear i have to be honest uh what
they're trying to do but it has had
people uh running and dispersing uh
pretty quickly the order of events today
uh assuming that it goes to any kind of
plan is that there will be a service
here at the catholic church in the old
city and then she will be taken just
around the corner probably four or five
hundred meters if that to a christian
cemetery uh just on the walls of uh
jerusalem's old city where she'll be
laid to rest alongside her mother and
her father
a lot of people i appreciate a lot of
people watching this might not have
heard of srinagar actually before she
was a journalist who worked for al
jazeera arabic but you know if she was
not known in the english-speaking world
she was very well known in the arab
speaking world she was palestinian
actually palestinian american but she
was palestinian she lived uh in the west
bank and she spent much of her career
covering events in occupied palestinian
territories so to many millions of
palestinians she was seen as their voice
and
in the days after her death we've heard
from uh colleagues and young
palestinians who say you know they would
grow up watching her
young palestinian women would
[Applause]
[Music]
grow up and
look at themselves in the mirror and
have a hairbrush and pretend they were
her so that gives you some idea of
her standing within the palestinian
community her influence in the
palestinian community and i think that
will help explain
uh the outpouring of emotion
and anger
at her death now in terms of
who killed her which is a contentious
question
[Music]
the palestinians are clear that she was
shot
by the idf in janine during a council
terrorism operation the idf say it is
unclear and they have released
preliminary findings within the last
hour that say it could have been an
israeli soldier but it could also have
been uh palestinians in janine who are
firing back so the idf says unclear
but to the crowds gathered here
it is certain she died at the hands of
the israeli forces that is absolutely
what they believe uh they believe that
she died a martyr they are angry that
she has been killed they are angry that
this voice that represented him has been
taken away
and emotions are running extremely high
as you can see from our pictures
but
if it goes according to plan she'll be
moved from here to the cemetery but at
the moment and we're only about an hour
into this uh ceremony
at the moment it is not going according
to plan and there have been ongoing
scuffles between israeli police and
mourners gathered
to remember her